is there uh any sort of ceremony i know
there's i'm sure a ceremony but
and maybe you're not allowed to say but
any uh tradition of how you greet a new
justice you know um is there any hazing
do you um
is there any are there any practical
jokes is there anything that's that's
that's done
you don't do projects
there there are certain traditions the
first one is
that when someone's nominated
the justices who sit
um don't typically reach out to the
nominee
i i presume that might be different if
you're very close friends with them
right
but if um you only know them somewhat in
passing the tradition is not to reach
out to correct until after the
confirmation process
and after the senate confirmed me
um i received calls from almost all of
my then colleagues
our colleagues to be
the first was from the chief judge and
then other calls followed
how justices welcome you to the court
varies
among the justices so when i came aboard
for example
justice stevens and justice o'connor
came to visit me
um
and uh and that was wonderful
when justice barrett came to the court
it was coveted so i couldn't just walk
over to her office and say hello
but i did
shortly thereafter
um
people call you people send you notes
that's what justice ginsburg did the
first day i arrived there was a note
on um on my desk from her
and it was very sweet welcoming me
aboard and giving me a copy of her bench
book
of her chambers book
which basically describes how she runs
her office right and it was invaluable
for a new justice starting out
um
so people have different ways of
welcoming each justice
but they will reach out in one way or
another either with a call or with a
visit
now i probably shouldn't this is the
kind of thing i'd be obsessed with but
if uh justin stephen breyer has been
there obviously quite a bit longer he
must have a really nice office
that office is now being vacated
do you get to do you get to move to that
office do you get that office i bet he's
got a real every every everyone except
the chief the chief has an office that's
designated just for the chief
but then they go down from the top of
the seniority list and they each ask
each justice in turn whether they want
to move
um i like justice breyer's office but i
love mine more
so
in fact
just they had gone to the predecessor
justices and asked me whether i wanted
to move and i said no so i'm going to
stay where i am well i think you should
think about that twice because
uh there's a lot of things to take into
consideration uh the rumor is breyer's
uh you know office is pretty sweet and
it is right next to it's right next to
the vending machine
[Laughter]
you get your snickers bar instantly
you should know that i'm on the second
floor
of the courthouse all my other
colleagues are on the first floor
the advantage of being on the second
floor is i get more sunlight in my
office very nice
it's bigger square footage than my
colleagues
number three
i can
decorate on the walls outside my office
which they can't because they're on the
historic first floor so they can't hang
anything outside their offices
and number four
they sit
one after the other
which means they have to be a bit quiet
because they can't disturb
the people on either side of them
i'm a bit loud
i like
laughing i like playing music on
occasion
um i talk loud
and so i like being on the second floor
okay i'm not bothering anybody and they
can't bother me have you ever gotten a
call from one of the other justices to
keep it down
no
okay
all right well i mean well you know we
have on on the first floor we have
marble
ceilings got it you've got this marble
yeah yeah and it keeps the noise from
traveling upstairs yeah we didn't have
that
i never had that growing up and neither
did